[Music]
this will happen to your kids i'll be
the first to stand up
i just want to come forward and have a
conversation
not
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products hey
guys so basically um
look we're here we just genuinely want
to have a dialogue with a discussion
uh a friendly debate maybe yeah so we're
here i don't know why obviously now it's
going to be i think
as you can see behind me uh the kids um
yeah
yeah so i know the thing is we're just
here we just have a nice discussion uh
but obviously people don't want to
dialogue
but i think what's gonna happen now is
maybe the police is gonna arrive but we
genuinely want to know we're just having
a genuine discussion
guys would you like to comment on what's
happening in israel no no
do you agree with what's happening
okay you can see we've been out here for
for a few minutes
after about five ten minutes the police
are already here
and uh so what's supposed to happen
what's the police here for go
can you tell us what happened at the
park today we had a beautiful discussion
with the sheikh
and one of the other guys here with this
brotherhood
and then the crowd started growing it
started threatening into our ears that
they're going to get us up if we don't
say ablc
and started getting right here so we
just had to run for all safety
and they were outside there and they all
came there followed us as well and we're
one of your brothers who said don't
worry
yeah but the point is this year we need
to understand brothers and sisters here
this that is anti-semitic that nobody
can come and say because we know
they're using the whole narrative of if
you talk against israel and symmetra i
don't buy that
i don't think you guys would buy it
because it's good it's as good as and
you might disagree with me
it's as good as isis coming and saying
your islamic hope for talking against us
that's why i believe
so the first thing is this year any
thunks i'm telling you well
i don't know if you're a muslim i don't
give a damn if you think you're brave
enough
to come and two people who come to the
park regularly where we have nice
discussions
i don't even let me tell you even if
their pro is israeli we will have an
intellectual discussion so i want to
make that very categorically clear
anyone that gets resourced to violence
against anybody
you're a weak individual
okay so basically we're doing a fellow
campaign
yeah maybe they're the members of
publishers asking them questions about
what's going on in israel yeah and what
they feel about it and just their point
of view
we tried to speak to some of them they
didn't want to left them what's
happening
afghanistan this is
68 people were killed in a in a by a
bomb by
uh i don't know yeah yeah yeah yeah no
one talks about that
can we get can we get some of your
opinions
you have innocent kids about yours
imagine if your kids this will happen to
your kids i'll be the first to stand
very fine i'll be the first to stand
against every other
many of these zionists right and yeah
it's clear that they're
going to ask the people that are coming
it's clear that they're zionists a lot
of them
are pro-israel and they're pro-policies
of israel as well you know
by the way we want to be clear if
somebody is
being butchered in this way i mean the
least you should be able to do
is have a conversation yeah provide you
a view
i mean why would you cross the road and
not be willing to engage
now in palestine they should they should
understand that they should realize that
people want answers people want to know
your opinion
so go go on record give your opinions
yeah discuss debate but it's not just
that it's that they're making their
little remark
and then they're moving or they're
giving their facial expression
and disgust and then they move what are
you disgusted about what are you
disgusting about well you want to show
them all angles
yeah you teach them whatever you want
but they they need to see this
you want to speak you should really give
your opinion about what's going on guys
that's why we're here yeah
based on how this conversation goes
honestly it can make a difference
between life and death
someone some zionist or some terrorist
or whatever
might get angered and aroused and then
start doing something which in the name
of judaism is
or islam whatever it is that will take
us 10 years back
what's on the side of the bank
so basically what we're doing is we're
just raising awareness to what's
happening
um it's something that you've already
seen in the media um
which is the killing of innocent people
and we don't know why we have those
faces
i don't know why it's basically
disappointment when palestinian kids
have been blown into pieces
i don't make that face you know if i saw
jewish kids been brought into pizza
with a special reaction but this is
what's happening so as you can see
um there you go there's nothing nobody
can find things
interesting
yeah compare and contrast something
ladies and gentlemen
i want to compare and contrast something
here ladies and gentlemen i want
everyone to hear me in fact
if you want to hear what i have to say
you can come closer so i want to compare
and contrast something
to be honest with lots of jews here and
we
as muslims we have no problem with jews
per se honestly we don't in fact
we believe in the same prophets who
believe in moses we believe in abraham
we believe in david who believe in
solomon however there's something i want
to say
and what i want to say to the people is
look there's lots of bad things
happening in the world in jerusalem
in the west bank in in israel if you
want to call it that
but the way forward from this is
discussion we want to show the world
that we can
communicate with each other that we can
have dialogue with another that we can
still show
amicability to one another that's what
we're here for we're not here to try and
attack anybody
but what i don't find particularly
convincing i have to say
i'll be honest with you because you guys
are my cousins i'm an arab you're a jew
you're my cousin so i want to be honest
because we're family you can co
you can just put your viewpoint whether
you agree with it or whether you don't
agree with it
just want to come forward and have a
conversation
to review your viewpoint
look guys let me tell you something and
let's be very clear
we're here to have conversations with
you yeah if you want to come and sneak
up
come and look at the the children being
destroyed and palestine and start
laughing
and saying that's afghanistan or making
the comments
we have the same thing in our
communities we have muslims who are
ultra conservative we have muslims who
are ultra intolerant
we have muslims who are terrorists we
have bad muslims
what i'm saying is this let me extend
my hand today to the jewish community
here and let me say to the people let us
start
a process of discussion let's get the
elephant out of the room
let's talk let's talk it out let's show
the world we can get along
the reason we came here today is the
show and just speak to our jewish
brothers and sisters in humanity those
who are zionists or those who are not
and just to ask
how they feel about what's going on the
ground that's all we came for we're not
here to
uh cause trouble anything like that
we're using our freedom of speech to
come and have a dialogue and say
how do you like what's your say on the
matter of what's going on in palestine
yeah
now there are there might be those who
are pro zionist israel
and there are those who oppose it so you
have the two spectrums here
you have the ones who are the orthodox
jews who are totally against the state
they
they expect that palestine belongs to
the palestinians and then you have
individuals who have been walking past
doing remarks we was filming here
somebody came and said oh is that
afghanistan i said that's not
afghanistan that's
israel you're a 21st century state who
are blowing up kids
we have a lot of bad muslims we
understand that and you know what else
we understand we understand that there
are a lot of good jews
do you know why i understand that i
understand that because the quran my
holy book tells me that
the quran says they are not all the same
jews and christians are not all the same
there are some of them you can trust and
you can be good friends with in some
which you can't and in fact the quran
says the same thing about muslim people
that some of them are valid some of them
are
oppressive to themselves and some of
them are middle
grounded and some of them are very good
so we're not generalizing anybody here
honestly
a child whether it be a palestinian
child or a jewish child
or a chinese child or a black child or a
white child or any child
to be blown into smithereens because
some guy decided
he wants to boost his political career
called netanyahu before some election
so he presses a button and all of a
sudden 200 people die
250 people die of them 60 or children
nothing funny about that my friend
there's nothing funny about that my
friend when i say that
60 children died which is 30 30
of those who were injured were children
playing in
yeah look at look they're pleased
they're gonna kill themselves
so what i'm saying is i just want to ask
you now what is your view
on the issues uh just generally oh open
question
open question is simple condemn violence
condemn death
and it should hurt me and you
for every innocent person or even a
combatant
because they only combatant because they
see no future they don't understand the
other side they don't understand each
other
and if they would only talk and find a
way to work each other's problems out
and understand each other's aspirations
then as we have spoken many times in the
past we'd understand each other and see
how much we would really agree
and i take it a step further i think
that the fact that
there is this belief in the world that
jews and muslims can't get along
is an imperialistic thing from
colonialist power like britain
who brought it to us to believe that
dividing and conquering people
is the way forward do you believe do you
agree then that
as the u.n says and human rights watch
and all of these organizations that the
actions of the israeli government have
not only been disproportionate
but they have been catastrophic for the
people of gaza and they have been
unwarranted in the sense
that the damage that has been done has
has been
something which really can't be undone
and unfortunately has caused more
problems in the middle east in that area
to what extent would you agree with a
lot of questions in this one there are
not a lot of questions to
to put together the simple concept is if
we're going to talk about
the what's happening now without going
into the recent course behind it
then it is yes to look at the current
form if you're going to look simply at
numbers are you going to look at the
reason
that yes it is something that is bad we
know it wants a house blown up no one
wants even a dog hurt in the side not in
gaza not in jerusalem
not in el cotes no way definitely
everyone would agree with that
but if you're going to go back and we're
going to take it a step backwards and
we're going to just go
first take facts and let's work with
that and work your way forward
and then work on our aspirations to
understand the two aspirations of two
people
right and i believe that these two
people could live together maybe in two
states or even in one state
and not all jews are the same believe me
not all of them are the same but this
guy he said
you know what he said some guy came and
said i said
children are being killed he said they
do get to themselves serious yeah they
go
this is this is very clear so i was just
having a discussion with them two jewish
guys there
um and one was look it's reasonable was
having a reasonable discussion it turned
into a dialogue a debate but the point
is this guys we're here to talk
things out okay we're not here he said
that a couple of days ago
and somebody was holding an israeli flag
and a muslim came and beat him up this
is disgusting we don't we're not
asking anyone to be anyone else
kids what are you talking about the
palestinian children i'm not the one who
brought them into it
it's the israeli government who brought
them into that i am not the one
i'm not the one who brought kids into it
my friend how
how how how kids palestinian children
are confusing
do you support it or not i do condemn
the killing of children
do you condemn it did you condemn it see
look at you
the silence is deafening i say that to
you today
i said do you condemn the israeli
killing of children
yes or no
yes
because the thing is as you can see
we've come here to talk yeah and as you
can see my sister's asking simple
questions like
do you condemn the kingdom of innocent
people and we've been told that they
bring up on their self
i mean imagine guys if he was here today
and a muslim carried out an action where
innocent people were killed
and i said uh and someone said you
condemn and i said you bring up on
yourself
it's as simple as i believe so i think
i think look we came here yeah we came
here i want to make this endless no yeah
yeah we came here to have a civilized
discussion i had a very nice discussion
over there
with with the jewish gentleman we had a
nice discussion we agreed to disagree we
had a bit of a
dialogue but they've shown intolerance
so so some have some have no there's a
lot of general most of them
no problem even if there's a hundred of
them doesn't mean that's all of them
we're gonna what we're gonna do now is
we're gonna leave because
it's we've come here to have a nice
discussion about we you've heard what
you've
heard robin sisters and once again these
are zionist jews
these are not your common jews that's
why they're very clear that's their
opinion
and this is what we're saying so any
kind of
attacks done towards muslims or jews we
condemn that it's as simple as that
we came here to have a discussion you
heard what they had to say
the zionist supporters by the way not
your layman your jew
yeah the designer supporters you heard
what they have to say and what they feel
about innocent children
being killed and that's why i'm gonna go
thank you for your time share and like
this video inshallah
and give your comments in the comment
section